we have an educational project than
Karen carry on e is one of the directors
of called teachers domain which Margaret
briefly talked about yesterday and what
teachers domain is an online education
resource K through 12 and it started
actually in the media library and
archives about 12 or 15 years ago when
we realized that we have a lot of video
content that could be used for
educational purposes so we created this
site which uses our video resources and
it's largely been science because our
archive for science is so large because
of the Nova collection that we have and
as we've added to it we had the last the
last grant we had was from the Hewlett
Foundation and the Hewlett Foundation of
course required that all the assets in
that in that next chapter be available
as open resources open content so what
we did it was pretty challenging and I
have to thank you look for pushing the
envelope with us but it was incredibly
difficult because what we did was we
took 15 or 20 assets so how many how
many were there from the well there were
900 but their new ones how many new ones
we had 20 new assets which we put into
this latest unit and then we had 900
assets that we were looking at which
meant that we were going back and
looking at all the previous content that
we had included in teachers domain to
see if we could make it available as
open content now you have to understand
we are professional documentary
filmmakers we a signatory to a number of
collective bargaining agreements with
writers actors musicians so we have a
sag agreement and after agreement we
have a director we don't have directors
guild but we have writers and after them
for musicians we've directors and the
after I just go
and then on top of that if you've ever
seen no but you know that there's a lot
of material that we didn't shoot so
there's a lot of third-party materials
and stock footage houses and archival
stills houses literally from around the
world and they're all subject to
different terms and conditions so we had
to sit down and think how are we going
to get these talent agreements which is
Josh talked about the trilogy the union
agreements still still look at
territorial restrictions they still look
at media so you have this kind of a la
carte menu when you look at rights and
the union agreements have been kind of
acknowledged convergence yet so you have
all of this legacy content which has
enormous and conferences so you have
archives you're clearing you have music
you're clearing and everyone knows
anecdotally how difficult it is to clear
music so you have all of these issues
and what happened for us in this last
grant that we had we we had to take
those 900 resources and figure how to
make them open and we weren't successful
in doing that because we couldn't change
the world we couldn't change copyright
law we couldn't change the way archives
do business and we certainly could not
change the way our union agreements
operate at this point in time although
our plans are to continue to work on all
these fronts so we had to come up with a
number of levels ranging from strikes we
already had for streaming only working
through three other levels ultimately
the last level was a fully downloadable
open resource which could be mixed and
mashed so we had at one end of the
spectrum something which was fully open
at the other end of the spectrum we had
something which could only be streamed
and in the middle we had something where
you could take that two-minute clip say
it's a two-minute clip of cells dividing
from Innova you could take that
two-minute clip but if that had other
resources that two-minute clip could be
used in another derivative work but only
as a two-minute piece you couldn't mix
and match with in that two-minute piece
whereas the last level you could mix and
match within them two minute piece so we
had these different levels for these 900
resources so the challenge that we had
was we approached Creative Commons in
and Eric to say is it possible to
develop a CC education license and
because a lot of our clearances for
educational purposes but once you once
you couldn't and we have the right to
create derivative works only at that
last level all requirements are that
they be non-commercial and of course we
would require that anyone give
attribution if they're using that
content but how do you guarantee your
license oars or the talent that you have
that you are in fact using those rights
for educational purposes because as we
know when something is downloaded to a
15 year old kids computer it's out there
in the ether it's out there in the world
so we approach creative comments about
doing an education license so that we
could get further assurance and then we
can then pass on the assurances to our
license oars or unions or whoever we
were dealing with that we were in fact
limiting what could be done and tag this
material as education content and
unfortunately the CC board rejected that
proposition for the reasons that Eric
cited they were concerned about the
proliferation of licenses and they want
to ensure the Opera operability of
licenses that's why we had to stick with
the four different levels that we have
because we felt that only in the level
the last level where it's fully mixable
you can create derivative works that
that was those are the clearances that
we got which did not have to be limited
to education and then and I really think
in a lot of ways it's a loss for us
because it creates a huge risk for us to
say okay we're going to move everything
to open content when in fact we don't
have those rights from our third party
rights holders so we're going to we're
still at it we're still looking to see
how we now queue up you know upcoming
labor negotiations this has resulted in
some real serious thinking about how to
possibly approach Congress and change
the copyright law and how to deal with
some stock footage and stills license
sores so it's cute us up for some work
that we will now spend a lot of time
doing over this upcoming year
in this arena but at this point in time
it's still incredibly complicated so
that's kind of the scenario that we had